من السجون لمنصات التواصل فاجنر تتفنن في
تجنيد المقاتلين خاصه وانها مقبله على
استحقاقات جديده في اوكرانيا خلال الايام
المقبله فبعد استراحه قصيره من مفرمه
اللحم التي تعرضت لها في بخمه بعد سحب
المساجين من سجونهم بدات المجموعه بالتوجه
نحو فيسبوك وتويتر ونشر الالاف الاعلانات
من اجل تجنيد اطباء ومشغلي طائرات بدون
طيار وحتى علماء نفس للمساعده في العمليات
القتاليه تنوعت اللغات التي اعتمدتها
فاجنر لتجد المقاتلين فاستخدمت الفرنسيه
مرورا بالفيتاميه وصولا الى الاسبانيه
طبعا عرضت رواتب مغريه تصل الى 2800 دولار
شهريا ورعايه صحيه ونشرت ارقام هواتف
وحسابات على تيليجرام للتواصل
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات